we could still be getting a season four
of the Orville but it might be missing
two of the most popular characters
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
I've been talking about the oval for a
little while now and it's been a little
bit of a on off sort of situation it
looked like it was very likely a few
months ago now the writer strike has put
us a few little doubts in place but many
of the actors have been talking about
how conversations have been happening
and the Disney would be Keen I
exclusively and first drop the news oh
God no six or seven months ago saying
that actually one of the big stumbling
blocks of this was simply money the
Orville New Horizons did very well for
Hulu and Disney plus internationally but
it did have quite a big budget it simply
cost too much money to make and they
needed to bring that in before they took
agree terms on a fourth season but there
is another big problem something that
again I've mentioned before
Seth MacFarlane is insanely busy right
his writing projects upcoming writing
projects not ones that he's already done
upcoming practice projects right now
he's got the Ted TV series that he is
completely writing he's got a Naked Gun
movie that he's doing he's got a project
called The Winds of War that he's doing
the screenplay on the story for that's
going to be a mini series and he's got a
drama series called the shrouded College
coming along as well that he is again
going to be at very least the writer for
perhaps more
so he has a lot of projects on the
horizon and
what I'm hearing is
Ed Mercer will not be returning for the
bulk of the fourth season of the Orville
that he will return initially but that
he will step back almost immediately due
to you know a death or me being a
promotion I actually he is more likely
to be a promotion but we don't know yet
five percent
that Kelly Grayson will then step up and
to become the captain of the Orville now
I am hearing that actually Seth
MacFarlane is doing this begrudgingly he
doesn't want to step away but he's got
so many other things on the go that he
may have to and to be honest production
company around him is just saying look
Ted is going to be a huge success we
have this Naked Gun movie that's going
to be hopefully a big deal the Orville
it's a close second but come on these
other things are more important and
they've Twisted Seth macfarland's arm
into doing it now I think and what I've
been told by my sources is that it's
more likely to be a promotion so then he
can step in and out of the show and he
can still do special appearances Etc I
think that would be the way he'd go
especially seeing that this is his show
he created it he's the showrunner
currently I'll come back to that in a
minute and it really is in lots of ways
his baby now this holiday about Kelly
Grayson becoming a captain he's actually
talked about that in interviews but I
think it was assumed at the time that
she met a captain of another vessel but
actually if this rumor is true and the
source is correct it actually will be
the captain of the Orville now what do I
think about this
I have to admit I love Seth MacFarlane
but he's possibly not the best actor in
the world and I think that's maybe Fair
um he is brilliant in the Orville but I
don't think he's that a massive part of
the series that it couldn't survive
without him especially if he stepped
back a little bit and but was still
around I think the show could move on
there are lots of other brilliant
characters in there and we do have
issues with things like that a lot of
the actors are actually only on
three-year contracts and those contracts
have ended so we're going to have to
either get new contracts or get new
actors in I do think this is an
opportunity to shake up this series and
to really
um give us something maybe a little bit
different moving forwards but that still
feels like the Orville because Seth
MacFarlane actually did create a
brilliant University it's more than just
a copy of Star Trek it actually deserves
to be a show in its own right and maybe
Seth macfarm is stepping back a little
bit wouldn't be a bad thing for the
overall longevity of the series but I
did say that two major characters were
going to be leaving the show Scott
Grimes plays Gordon Malloy now he is
going to be starring in the new Ted TV
series that is already sort of sorted
um they go into pre-production at the
moment I believe a lot of the filament's
already done that's actually going to be
our screens recently soon now the people
over at peacock think they have really a
big hit on the hands potentially with
Ted and they really want to tie him and
Scott Grimes down to a long-term deal
that deal would probably prohibit him
from returning as Gordon Malloy I'm
hearing that that basically is the plan
and we won't get Ed or Gordon returning
for the new series of the Orville
now what do I actually think of that in
the first couple of Seasons particularly
Gordon Malloy was probably my favorite
character he was really of one of the
main funny characters he had the great
sort of like half-assed attitude towards
things I really do think men in
particular looked at him and went that's
probably what I'd be like if I was
aboard a Starship
but I do think in the third season he
became a little bit too serious at times
and I think I don't know they lost the
way of the character so I don't want to
see him go but I wouldn't be as
disappointed now as I would have been if
he'd gone at the end of season one for
example I have to admit though I'm not
100 certain this show can survive losing
two of the more popular characters
they're gonna have to bring in new
characters and really do this as a fresh
start if the show is going to survive
but will Seth MacFarlane still be
writing many of the episodes or still
show running well I'm actually being
told again that he's probably going to
step back from those duties as well even
though he may jump in with the odd
episode here and there he's probably
going to hand off much of the series to
other writers and there were lots of
other writers that have worked on the
series people like Joe manowski Brennan
Braga and Andre bermanis
these people have worked on the show for
a few years and I'm actually hearing
that bran and Braga may be returning as
the new showrunner now he didn't work on
the series in the last series a great
deal so this would be him coming back to
the Orville he was more involved in the
first two seasons you would know the
Brannan Braga name because you'd have
appeared in the credits of an awful lot
of Star Trek over the years the original
the good Star Trek so how would I feel
about him returning as showrunner and
actually writing several episodes along
with another team I'm very happy about
it if you're going to lose Seth
MacFarlane bring in someone like Brandon
Braga who really has that Heritage of
great sci-fi behind him and actually
already knows an awful lot about what
the Orville is and what makes it a
brilliant show so this will no longer be
Seth MacFarlane's baby he's going to
have to hand it over to somebody else if
we're going to get a fourth season of
the Orville
I'd love to know what you guys think
about that is this the death of a really
unique and interesting Sci-Fi show or is
this a new beginning
should they bring back a little bit more
of the humor from the first two seasons
to you know make it a little bit
different to Star Trek could this
actually be a rebirth of this show or do
you actually think losing two major
characters like that and the show or and
the major writer all in one hit is just
too much I would actually argue that we
could get a more rounded Sci-Fi show
this way but at the end of the day this
was Seth MacFarlane's the Orville
without him
I'm not 100 certain the show Will
Survive now don't get me wrong this is
not like Henry Cavill leaving The
Witcher that has killed that show it is
done I don't even know why they're
bothering
that McFarland though is still involved
and still you know jumps in and out
I think it could survive
but I'd love to know exactly what you
think get in the comments while I'm here
and I've got you please check out the
description because I do have a petition
running concurrently regarding Stargate
and I would love you guys to drop your
signatures I really want Stargate to
return and I want Brad Wright the
original creator of the sg1 series
universe and Stargate Atlantis to be
involved somehow but we need to give MGM
a little bit of a push he has allies at
MGM we need to remind them what we want
and why it is so important for Brad
right to be involved so please check the
description and go and sign the petition
if you haven't already or share it with
your friends because we need to get as
many names on there as we can if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you will never miss any
of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and for a small contribution each
month that really supports the channel
you don't have to watch the adverts
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign